i want to talk about what this is really
about
the kyle rittenhouse case is about more
than kyle rittenhouse it's about more
than the riots
this may be one of the most
consequential cases of our lifetimes as
the rioters traveled across the country
last year burning down buildings and
smashing windows
with the reporting from michael tracy
some of the most important i've ever
seen where he actually went to these
small towns you've never heard of and
saw the damage from the riots
they have defended these rioters they
have protected people like gage
grosskroitz when the when the
prosecution instructed the defend the
detectives not to execute search
warrants take a look at this story from
the daily caller the prosecutor in the
written house trial says you lose the
right to self-defense when you're the
one who brought the gun a major
component of this trial
this is not about kyle rittenhouse in
the bigger picture it is about your
right to keep and bear arms now i will
say
when you look at constitutional carry
gun rights have been winning
but this is a major assault on the
culture around it we can win in the
courts we can win in the legislature but
if they can set precedent that if you
bear a gun you are always the pro
provocateur always the instigator and
never intended self defense that's the
argument being played here if the jury's
sides with the prosecution you will you
will start hearing attempts where they
say in the case of writ you know the
state v written house the the the jury
found that you know if you're bringing a
weapon to a fist fight you are provoking
blah blah blah i don't i'm probably
getting this a bit wrong i'm not a
lawyer so maybe that context isn't
correct maybe it's precedent has to be
said from a judge or something like that
as a question of law the point is
they're trying to make a cultural moment
occur
where kyle reynolds is guilty simply
because he brought a gun now mind you
the question's been answered the judge
this was the most amazing moment i was
screaming i was like yes
the judge
said
to the prosecution
as a question of law because that's what
the judge deals with
the the the charge count six on illegal
possession of a deadly weapon by a
person under 18. he is exempt because he
was 17. he looks at the prosecution and
said can you prove the rifle he he had
was under 26 inches and krause goes it
was not under 26 inches and the judge
goes count just count six dismissed
it was not an illegal weapon i think 16
inches is the correct length because if
it's 20.96
yeah so barrel length is 16. 26 overall
i believe um or might be 32 i'm not sure
the point is
the judge definitively said
dismissed the law is not that
complicated in my opinion it says
if you are under 18
and in violation of these provisions
which state you're under 16 without a
permit you're under 14 without a
guardian or whatever or you're hunting
without a certificate okay well kyle
right now doesn't is is not violating
any of those statutes 17 year olds are
allowed to bear only rifles and shotguns
kyle right now said he knew he couldn't
have a handgun but i want to get back to
the the main point here that we need we
need to make sure we're paying attention
to if kyle ryden house loses
they have that argument they will use it
it will become culture and law is
meaningless in the face of culture i've
pointed this out many times you guys all
understand this there are laws like you
can't put an apple pie on your window so
on tuesday those laws still exist
they're archaic and no one will ever
enforce them why well that would be
absurd because culturally
we don't do that anymore but the law is
there and they could get you another
problem would a jury really convict you
of an 1800s pie law or something like
that give you a fine i i doubt they
would
but this is what's important if culture
emerges where in the media in our in our
all of our institutions if you have a
gun you are considered an instigator in
any capacity you will never be able to
use a gun to defend yourself they will
always convict you really encourage
people to watch the trial it is a very
it's a blessing that we have this
available just to know to to see the
smarminess of this guy and this little
finger i mean he looks like an acts like
little thing it's crazy how much these
like little fingers he does yeah it's
true and and kyle i mean particularly
kyle's testimony
because he's just like uh it was like
his hometown or like his dad lived there
and it was like a city his grandma lives
there his dad lives there he works there
his best friend's there
burnt down it's a carmax
car
yeah that's terrifying man he's like a
young american who was like i need to
defend my city
it's really crazy how the how bad ben
and jerry's lied to this this is this is
the funniest thing i tweeted even ice
cream lies and we know ben and jerry's
is full of garbage but they tweeted what
what if a 17 year old you know black
person care a black kid carried a rifle
across illegally across state lines and
killed three white people as if what
happened was a white person carried open
across state lines and killed three
black people which it didn't their skin
color did not matter when they were
charging at that guy i don't care if
kyle rittenhouse is white black asian
male female five feet tall six feet tall
well it's funny how they're like this is
really important for self defense as
well jank uger was like so how would the
right feel if uh if a black teenager
brought a rifle to a protest and then
shot people and claimed self-defense and
every two-way person was like oh we
would defend him oh for sure
yeah you know you know what i really
love
when i was tweeting about 2a and the
absolute rights and people were like i'd
like to see you defend the black
panthers having guns tim and i said
something like abs so effing lutely
every black panther should be armed they
are allowed to walk down those streets
they are allowed to be in this country
going wherever they please with whatever
gun they want and then these socialists
were like based
i'm like do you think we don't want
people to have the right to bear arms
and defend them exactly it's for
everybody it's for everybody that's an
american citizen we have the second
amendment here in the united states
whether left or right and it's like
they've made it like it's
all people but what's interesting is how
this has been so spun if if kyle gets
convicted he will be the poster child
for an active shooter and anytime
there's some kind of active shooting
this is not an active shooting situation
but they're going to use it as that so
now moving forward in the united states
of america whenever we do have some kind
of situation like that kyle rittenhouse
he will become some kind of poster child
that's going to be used to attack the
second amendment at the same time but
this is what they do the they'll take
something that's a minority i mean we
have active shootings happening in the
united states right
but it's not like this
insane pandemic or crazy thing that's
happening in the united states that's
out of control for the most part people
are responsible gun owners right um but
they do the same thing with covet as
well there's a minority of numbers but
they they blasted across the entire
society where everyone has to be on
lockdown even though there's a minority
of people that could actually die from
they do this with everything they take
the minority and they just spread it
everywhere i want to address that i
don't think first first of all
let me just say i want to say i had
covet and i had it really really bad and
i think the m2 i think the important did
you have it really really bad yeah i
survived i had it like legit me and ian
had a really best but i want to say this
i got really sick other people didn't
get really sick some people got sniffles
yeah and so this is why i'm like i
actually think kovit's bad and we want
to take it seriously but we can't do a
one-size-fits-all policy that's my point
but so so ultimate but i don't want to
just get into covet my my main issue
with it is
i don't think it's necessarily that the
media
uh uh and the establishment
i should say the establishment and the
elites do this on purpose but for the
bigger picture in the media the reason
why they highlight every fringe case the
reason why it seems like the apocalypse
is happening with covet is because
the media finds the story and reports it
but they don't report the non-story so
this is what happens with antifa
antifa goes out and they punch someone
in the face is that national news
no of course not this is not
they do it 500 times not a single
instance is national news
they riot across the country
some of it reaches national news because
it is low-level sustained terrorism we
don't hear about it all that much the
mainstream media first of all the
establishment they're biased kamala
harris actively fundraised for these
people so of course there's that and
then there's the media component of
local news outlets for instance that
aren't as you know not always wrapped up
in the manipulation local news do a good
job but they're not going to report on a
guy getting punched
now what happens if one fringe far right
winger gets a gun and goes and commits
an atrocity
international headlines and rightly so i
think rightly so absolutely it's bad
it's abhorrent we've got to stop these
people before they can take you know
carry this stuff out it's difficult to
figure out how to do that but everyone
will hear about it
and then for those of us that are in the
news and reading the stories we know
that antifa does this
regular people don't because they never
hear it it's not just little crimes i
mean there's people burned alive there's
people shot there was a police officer
trying to stop looting that was
literally shot point blank on on live
streams and it went viral on the
internet but it wasn't really that
prominently talked on the mainstream
media but but i think what's happening
here is that obviously this case is
politically polarized obviously a lot of
ways on this particular case and i think
that's why there's so much attention on
it there's so much hype on it because i
think the establishment wants to use
this case as an example of you can't
defend yourself if you are a gun owner
you have a gun you get attacked uh you
have to get attacked and and that's an
absurd assertion that they're making
which essentially will leave a lot of
people defenseless and i think that's
why a lot of people who are pro second a
are you know biased in this case and
obviously have something that weighs for
them in this matter for the left a lot
of their agenda weighs on this court
decision so this is going to have huge
ramifications i really want to be
careful with the left and the right
leftists socialists love guns for
everybody two ways for everybody it is
it is younger populist socialist lefty
types
there are four gun rights it is the
establishment liberal
democratic authorial liberal for the
most part
to go to luke's point i think you're
right real quick i'm sorry i'm sorry i
gotta say i gotta say one one real quick
thing on this because i can't let this
one slide the left loves guns until the
leftists love guns until they get the
power then they'll take your guns
yeah i i think to go to luke's point is
i think they might even want to do this
to discourage people from even wanting
to buy a gun in the first place oh you
want to buy a gun for self-defense well
look what happened to kyle rittenhouse
if if legal legally
if kyle gets convicted right i'm
speaking hypothetically oh you want to
buy a gun for self-defense well look
what happened to him if that happens to
you you're going to end up in that
position too so i think that could
potentially discourage an entire
generation from even wanting to own a
firearm and literally uphold their
second amendment even without the
verdict look at the way that the
mainstream media responded to this they
called them a white supremacist they
called them an active shooter they
called them guilty
without even the trial beginning big
tech social media censored people
mainstream media organizations we should
corporate media organization showed up
at people's doors for donating ten
dollars to him people who were in police
departments were fired for donating 25
for him uh so so already we're having
him uh kind of prosecuted in the eyes of
big tech social media the corporate
media which is going to discourage a lot
of people already with this trial that
happened with a lot of people's
viewpoints we have to understand no
matter what the jury decides here
there's a bigger verdict that's going to
be kind of decided by the general public
here that absolutely weighs and i think
you could see that today by some of the
judges comments he's he he looks like
he's reacting to a lot of the outside
influences here that are trying to push
for a particular outcome for this case
so when this happens i mean this to me
is just like the perfect divide and
conquer agenda i think this is why we're
getting so much play on it because
there's so much weighing on this and i
think a lot of the establishment are
seeing this as an opportunity to ram
through a lot of their absolutely crazy
policies that would disarm people that
would leave them defenseless and at the
end of the day i mean i don't know if
this is the perfect case to make a stand
here but this is a very offensive case
that the establishment is making here
i'm uh i'm actually scared
if kyle rittenhouse does get convicted
this is not the story of an evil
ideologue this is the story
of a 17 year old who said i want to help
everybody this is the story of a 17 year
old who went to kenosha where his father
lives where his grandmother lives where
he works where his best friend lives
where he drives through every day and
said i will actively help even those who
are rioting who rendered aid to people
and asked if they needed medical
assistance even though he's clearly not
with them as an ideologue or protester
kyle rittenhouse wasn't there for the
right he wasn't there for the left he
was just there to help he didn't want
fires he didn't want destruction and he
didn't want those protesting to get hurt
either so i keep bringing this up as
something stephen crowder talked about
he says this isn't really kyle on trial
here which is great poetry oh great i
gotta adjust my my turn up a little bit
yeah hold on let me let me just set this
isn't kyle on track hear me how's that
yeah this is all of us on trial yeah it
is it's everyone and he's right because
kyle is a normal person who's just
trying to help his community and people
took issue with this being his community
because he didn't live there he worked
there he had family there like if this
isn't your community what is your
community it's not just your literal
neighborhood yes
or your government address right exactly
kenosha was a crime scene it was a crime
scene it was literally a crime scene and
what people need to understand is
there was a threat to the community i
mean when i came okay the first night i
was there
uh drove back to chicago did a hit with
fox that night and then went all the way
back the third night back to the kenosha
scene when i got back i was talking to
some of the locals i interviewed them i
asked them are you a black lives matter
supporter this is on twitter druihlive
you can see the interview i asked her
are you a black lives matter supporter
in broad daylight and i was like do you
condone uh the violent writing and she
says yes this is the only way that we
can have our voices heard
you were there the first night and the
third
this is the this is the the day of the
kyle written house shooting i'm asking
these kind of questions with to these
people and this is what they're saying
okay so also i'm walking around i'm
talking to some of the locals i
interviewed the people that had their
businesses burned down to the ground and
they're just confused they're like what
do we have to do with jacob blake right
and i'm walking around the the the
community you're seeing boarded up
windows they're writing children live
here on them why do you think they're
doing that for peaceful protesters you
think they're scared of peaceful
protesters no there's violent criminals
that showed up with a political agenda
to burn down a building that had to burn
down a community that had nothing to do
with him even right now tim right now
when i was in kenosha i'm driving down
the street i show up i'm just kind of
like having flashbacks i'm i'm like
looking around i'm like this is crazy
surreal to be here again i drive by a
building it's a senior citizen home
the building is boarded up right now wow
and it says right now on the building
the same thing senior citizens live here
even right now they're afraid there's a
threat why why are they afraid right now
why are they because there's a threat
even right now why is the national guard
called out right now because of peaceful
protesters yes because hold on
has anyone reported we expect a guilty
verdict no
across the board from chris hayes to
anna kasparian the narrative has been we
were wrong about cal right now he's
gonna be acquitted
now they're preparing for riots how long
can they keep lying to the american
people about what the violence is who
the violence is coming from thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you